inside this 270 000 gallon tank
live over 600 animals ranging from
sharks
to tiny fish National Aquarium in
Baltimore brings in around 1.3 million
visitors a year but what guests don't
always see is what goes on to keep all
these animals alive from turning salt
pallets into seawater to training the
fish I kind of have to be a Jedi with
this to scrubbing the unique 3000 piece
replicated coral reef system National
aquariums total operations add up to 45
million dollars a year
the black tip reef exhibit was renovated
with 12.5 million dollars and eight
hundred thousand dollars went to this
entire replicated Coral race system so
maintaining this expensive habitat is a
top priority three times a week scuba
certified divers gear up to clean the
exhibit in total when you look at this
equipment and you add a mask to it it
can be about two thousand dollars to
outfit one diver these acrylic pads
originally used for car washing
also work on the viewing windows since
we're very buoyant in the water we use
suction cups to help keep us anchored to
the window one of the most time
consuming tasks we have is hand
scrubbing because the algal growth is
regularly occurring we have these larger
utility brushes that are good for an
overall area we have these awesome grout
brushes that really help into getting
into some of those smaller areas and
better on more textured areas and these
little toothbrushes are really great
when it comes to brushing some of those
more detailing areas this cast Coral
cost anywhere from 25 to 1700 a piece
animals are used to the divers like Zoe
who gets close because she's curious
about the Bubbles they create but not
all animals in the exhibit are
considered safe so the divers have to
constantly be aware of their
surroundings we do have some hazardous
animals in there with spines and dive
cleaning is just the first step in
quality control when it comes to the
water the next line of defense behind us
is the water filtration systems
so all the animals in black tip reef are
completely relying on this set of
equipment that we're looking at this
exhibits life support system is
monitored 24 7. we actually have two
people at all times any given night
first this denitrification system helps
remove toxic nitrates which creates
healthy living conditions and mitigates
algae growth a second filter backwash
process takes water from the exhibit
filters it before pumping it back this
system prevents roughly 2.7 million
gallons of water from being discarded
annually that's a lot of seawater that
we would be throwing away it's very
expensive with this system the aquarium
only needs to replace a portion of black
tippery squatter at a time and instead
of sourcing seawater the aquarium makes
its own with these 2500 pound salt
pellets the animals that we are
supporting in these habitats have
learned to survive in that vast full
complement of seawater ions if any of
them are missing it can throw that
internal process off balance
it takes eight of these pallets to
create a batch of replicated seawater
which can be used for all the aquariums
seawater exhibits and thanks to black
tip reef filtration systems the exhibit
only needs around 20 000 gallons of new
seawater every three months saving the
aquarium roughly 450 thousand dollars a
year
to fill this tank with living animals
the aquarium had a budget of about 325
thousand dollars some of these fish cost
nearly 8 500 each to ship from Australia
but in the past some of the predator
species have eaten the smaller fish
which is why it is crucial to keep the
apex predators well fed Pepe is our
black blotched Stingray and trained he
is quite rambunctious oh
the exhibit spends about twenty one
thousand dollars a year on feed for the
animals feed varies by species ranging
from mackerel and Squid to Krill and
pellets
and in total the black tip reef goes
through about 6 700 pounds of Feed in a
year the eight sharks in this exhibit
beat 30 of that we're going to be
working with Zuri today so she'll be
receiving her food her diet during the
training session
this buoy guides Zuri the shark on where
to swim
and this orange Target signals where to
stay
it took Missouri a few months to learn
to Target and to really follow the
target
she was very curious about the platform
but staying nice and still in calm is a
bit of a challenge for her aquarists
also use feeding sessions to train an
animal for routine health checks
other animals that go through training
sessions include the pack of black tip
reef sharks Australian whiptail Rays Zoe
the other zebra shark and Bertha the
Queensland grouper
she's still working on it
we use positive reinforcement training
in order to help us do as many things
with them as we can with as little
stress as possible The more stress and
animal experiences of course the more
negative Health ramifications that can
have predators get fed separately from
the rest of the fish and during feeding
aquarists will monitor for unusual
behavior of all 630 animals there is the
chance that we would need to move a fish
to a different exhibit for instance if
they are not getting along with another
fish in the habitat we might need to
separate the two fish or perhaps they
are eating things that might cause them
harm some animals like Duncan the puffer
fish were relocated because they were
eating the coral which didn't cause any
medical issues but did damage the reef
Duncan will likely be replaced with
other creatures which will continue the
aquarium's conservation and education
initiatives adding animals into the
black to brief habitat is something that
typically takes place about once a year
the National Aquarium generated 430
million dollars in tourist-related
economic impact in 2022 and new
residents could bring in more guests
guests who have come to know the black
tip reef habitat for a long time knew
Calypso who was a green sea turtle
although we were devastated to lose her
in 2020 we are excited at the prospect
of hopefully being able to add another
green sea turtle into black tip reef in
the future
[Music]
foreign